hi i'm maisie williams and this is the
wired autocomplete interview
only bad things come from googling
yourself
[Applause]
when did maisie williams turn into an
assassin
shortly after birth no i'm i'm guessing
that this is asking during my time on
game of thrones i think it was around
season five arya starts to do some
pretty intense training across the
narrow sea in braavos gets beaten up a
lot of times and then ultimately becomes
a faceless man
when did maisie williams
start acting game of thrones was my
first role and i was cast in that on the
7th of august 2009 i have it written
down here for memory that was the
beginning of it all i kind of had only
really acted in school plays up until
that point and then i was acting in
front of the world so i had to learn
fast
when did maisie williams become famous
shortly after starting acting hbo took
care of that
um yeah when i was about 12 years old or
maybe 13 by the time the show came out
when is maisie williams in doctor who
i am in three episodes of doctor who i
played a girl called a shielder but then
she changed her name to me i believe
the doctor made her immortal and she
became very bitter because of it it's
very hard to watch everyone that you've
ever loved
die and still remain i guess that gave
me a bit of insight into what that would
be like
how maisie williams
how is maisie williams honestly
never been better i feel grateful for
this day and
for this little piece of cardboard
how many tattoos does maisie williams
have i have a couple um i don't know how
many two three
four five
six seven seven tattoos and i want to
get more
uh but i usually just get them as
impulse tattoos the same day
that i decide what i'm gonna get so it's
less about what the tattoo is and more
about the day that it happens maybe i'll
get
how maisie williams with a little google
logo on my back to commemorate this
oh i did the wrong one oopsie
okay
how many movies has maisie williams been
in
i'm not sure
but um i loved each and every one of
them
no that sounds silly i don't i actually
yeah i'm not sure 12 potentially it's a
one for each month of the year
how
to
contact maisie williams just uh cool
into the ether
and i will hear you
oh i can hear someone
now oh yeah
sorry i'm a bit busy
why did maisie williams
dye her eyebrows
i bleached my eyebrows for this role
that i had played last year i um played
a girl a woman called jordan for danny
boyle's show about the sex pistols and
she was a fashion icon at the time and
worked in vivian westwood shop and so i
bleached my eyebrows she i when i met
jordan she said how do you feel about
waxing off all your eyebrows because i
don't have any eyebrows
and obviously confronted with that
question from the very person that
you're playing i said yeah absolutely i
would do that that's fine
and then i spoke a little bit with ivana
our makeup artist and she said actually
we could probably just get away with
bleaching them why maisie williams
meme
i don't
think i'm in a meme there was a couple
of memes from game of thrones for sure
i'm not sure
why
didn't arya kill jamie at the twins i
don't know probably plot hole
uh courtesy of david and dan so
take it up with them
no don't they they've
they've had enough
yeah i'm not sure um she probably just
like didn't feel like it that day
she was busy
washing her hair okay
why
maisie williams honestly
i ask myself this every day
why anything
what
is
short oh wait what is maisie short for
my full name is margaret my real name is
margaret so i guess it's short for that
but
it's not actually the correct like it
would make more sense if i was called
maggie or something like that because my
parents actually went in the reverse
order
it's confusing it doesn't make any sense
they came up with my nickname and then
they said what should we put on her
birth certificate and then they were
like well if we want maisie we should do
margaret
but i actually think that maisy is a
uh
like derivative
of
dottie or something and that's then
dorothy so i actually think i should be
called dorothy williams
maybe i've made this up who knows i
should google it but
you can
instead anyway margaret
what is maisie williams favorite food
kimchi
i
eat
jars and jars and jars of kimchi
it's the best food ever
and it's good in every continent what is
maisie williams binge watching i just
finished binge watching
uh what was it called we crashed that
was amazing
and then now i'm watching bloodline and
i'm like halfway through the first
series and i didn't know what i thought
it was going to be but it's like
completely different and i'm really
loving the
just like emotional arcs of all of the
characters and it's great because i've
still got like two more series to go so
it's kind of nice when you come to
something a little bit later
what
happened to sophie turner and maisie
williams nothing happened we uh saw each
other at the mat actually which was
really lovely and in a room full of
strangers it's really nice to see
someone that you just know we don't live
in the same continent anymore which is
heartbreaking but whenever she's in the
uk or whenever i'm here then we try to
hang out maisie williams and sophie
turner are still in love
what maisie williams dream role
that's a good question i'd love to play
kate bush i'd honestly anything i'd like
to do a lot of things but kate bush
would be fun i think that she's really
interesting i think she's got a really
interesting story as well but it's quite
like uh
it's a bit arrogant
to be like i want to play kate bush
because like who knows if i should play
kate bush but if the opportunity arrives
and i did a good enough audition then
i'd love to play kate bush what is
next for maisie williams
i am on a new show called the new look
which is about christian dior and
coco chanel during the 1940s and the
rise
slash fall of their
fashion houses
and i play catherine dior which was
christian's younger sister an incredible
woman so yeah i'm having a good time
app harry
can maisie williams
speak targaryen i
cannot and also i think it's dothraki
not targaryen i think targaryen is just
english
so i can speak targaryen
now like that's probably incorrect and
i'm going to whatever can maisie
williams sing yes i can
incredibly
um
i can i can sing in the shower i can
sing as well as i can
ride horses
and i don't do that often
i don't know where i'm going with this
can maisie williams swim yes
like a fish
can maisie williams
play instruments no
but i'd like to learn i'd love to be
able to play piano maisie williams
pistol yes this is the new show that i'm
in and it's about sex pistols based on
steve jones's book called a lonely boy
and i play
the wonderful icon jordan mooney and the
show is incredible and you can watch it
soon is maisie williams in a
relationship yes i am i've been very
public about it
yes i am i'm in a relationship with a
wonderful man named ruben selby
is maisie williams a twin
people used to say
christina ritchie i got that a little
bit which is really really flattering i
was like really are you sure i don't
know how christina richie would feel
about that but
for me huge compliment is maisie
williams
in elden ring i'm not no
but i do have a sword from
the elden ring game and a cape
and
i haven't even played it i have it but i
don't have it on the right console
so
i'm not in it maisie williams podcast
yes i have a podcast called
frankfilmclub and it's a club where we
watch movies and then get together and
chat about what we thought and develop
our own opinions and try to
harness what we think rather than just
going with opinions that we've heard
expressed before and it's great fun
should check it out does maisie williams
play fortnite i do i do play fortnite
and i really enjoy it and i like the
customizing
customization of it so catch you there
at bigfoot maze
does maisie williams have a tick tock i
do
but
it's not under my name i can't even
remember what name it's under but i do
it's good fun to just make things on
there i like tick tock does maisie
williams
win an emmy
i didn't
yet
i was nominated and i was
just
um couldn't believe it actually but next
on the list is
to win
um but also it doesn't
it's whatever happens happens
did maisie williams
get to keep needle they always said that
i would
but i actually didn't i think that it's
in an exhibition or something like this
so at some point i hope that it will
make its way back home
to me
but for now it's you know
doing the doing the tour world tour so i
have to be patient
okay
well i hope you've enjoyed this video i
love watching these videos so i won't be
watching this one
but i hope for you viewers it's as
enjoyable as the other ones